does media affect your mental health
find out on this episode of led live
light exposing darkness
welcome everyone to another episode of
led live today we are excited because we
have several guests on our show today
and we are going to be unpacking the
topic of mental health
and the various aspects around that
specifically with media
so today we have with us dr and mrs
heldzinger and we also have
denis who used to volunteer for our
ministry
little light some number of years ago
that's right so
welcome everybody and we're glad that
you're here today to talk about mental
health with us
thank you happy birthday i want to know
a little bit how did you guys get into
this field or
what's what's kind of your expertise in
this area
well i'm a i'm a family physician and
as i have a board certification
in family practice and so i see people
of all walks of life i'm a generalist a
general doctor
so the more i work the more i realize
that even my young people that you would
think would be people that would be
happy
in life life is just starting you got
youth you got all this yes
you've got everything going for you and
suddenly we realize that
a lot of these people are taking
antidepressant medications or any kind
of
mood altering drug or even the younger
people have issues with sleep yeah
and so that kind of got me a little bit
more interested in
wanting to deal with the the mental
aspect of health because we know that
our mental health plays an incredible
role in
our physical health right it drives you
i mean it it can it can really take you
out or it can put you in a different
path or you know yeah for sure yeah and
so as
we started doing those things and uh
things i came across
dr neil nedley's book depression the way
out and we became
quite interested in that and then i had
the privilege to be able to
work with him in his residential
recovery program
at weimar i received some training there
and we started
doing the the uh community-based
educational programs from our church as
an outreach
uh to the community and so we really
enjoyed that
and then later on became more interested
in
doing a residential program
on the east coast and so we've i've
actually had the privilege to run three
residential programs in atlanta with
people over a year so we've had probably
about 60
patients come through that program which
was really exciting we really enjoyed it
and then i was really
hooked on this and really loved it
because you can really make an
impact on people's lives yeah so
for our audience sake let's let's unpack
a couple of these things
you mentioned nedley's depression the
way out why did you gravitate
toward dr nedley's program and i'm
asking because i know the answers but
there's a specific reason why you would
choose his program over any other
program that's out there why dr nedley's
program
well when when you look at the research
and the research looks at for instance
counseling and it doesn't matter what
kind of counseling it is
and included into that group was
christian counseling
they compared the efficacy of that over
a period of time
and what they found was that there was
actually no difference
and that kind of surprised me because
you would think that christian
counseling would have an edge
over other kind of counseling and so
then they went back and they looked at
that and they
realized that unless you address
somebody's core beliefs what they
believe in their minds
and their thoughts doesn't matter what
kind of counseling you do
you can only modify people's behavior
for a while but you're not going to
change them yeah you got to get to the
root you got to get to the root
and this program is the only program
that i know of that actually deals with
the
causes of depression and dr natalie
has published a a paper on
the basic hits of depression
and the hypothesis surrounding that and
that's really what
what drew me to that and how does it
compare to other programs
and efficacy as you were talking about
like
on you know of all the programs that are
available
how effective is his program compared to
other programs
oh way way more effective i mean we're
looking at
efficacy rates of above 90 even for the
the the community based program which is
an outpatient once a week program
uh and if you do the the the boot camp
program which is the
the residential program uh it goes up
over 94 percent of efficacy
uh so so let that sink in for a second
we're talking about
a 90-plus percent recovery rate if you
put in the effort and you do everything
if you do everything you do everything
yes
without medication absolutely without
medication
or decreasing yeah that's amazing yeah
yeah like show me another
medical program that has that high of uh
efficacy rate that's astounding yeah i
can remember when we first came across
neil's um books uh i read
parts of proof positive and that was
hugely impactful to me
and we actually made a documentary way
back in the beginning of our ministry um
it was called pseudology and it really
dealt with
the sort of effect that media has on the
brain
and uh neil nedley had an incredible
amount of
of insight into this correlation and
connection to
the way that the media impacts our
frontal lobe and all this i remember
kind of mostly what i learned was was
actually
from him and uh i got a chance to
actually um
interview a couple people that had gone
through his program over the years
and so um as the interview was kind of
getting going
uh the question was asked so what you
know when you came in this
program and you're super depressed what
was the first thing that they did and he
said give me your phone and give me your
ipad
and literally took away every form of
media and he was like
we can't even get to square one unless
you remove this
and that was kind of an interesting
thing to me yeah you first increase
their anxiety before you can decrease it
yeah right we've seen people crying just
because the
phone was taken away even though in the
program they still would get an hour a
day
or 45 minutes a day that they can call
their family but
literally people are crying weeping
because they have to be separated from
their
phones isn't that crazy yeah that's
classic sign of addiction
it's a coping mechanism for a lot of
people you know
um i i went through the program myself
was it 2018 i think it was
she's an alumni of our community-based
program and look at this joyous smiling
face right here
when she came into the program she was
like i know emotionally
you know a result of that i am part of
the 90 something percent then i can
definitely say it worked
um but yes i went through it and and um
yeah like i i mean it's it's definitely
easy
to just you know pull up your phone and
think of something else for a second
just tune out yeah and it's harder to
say okay lord i'm actually going to give
it to you
and i'm going to go through the mental
processing i'm trying to figure out why
am i feeling this way and all that
it's easy to just pull it out and just
forget about it and just shut it off and
i think that's why people
here are so um you know like when it's
so hard for them
um but yeah like i went through the
program and a year later i took the
training and now i'm a small group
facilitator yes and we're now
facilitating the program together
you know what a beautiful thing you're
talking about small group in a
depression
yes so so there's a lecture an hour-long
lecture and then there is
a an hour-long small group where we use
this workbook it's just been heavily
used because i've been doing this for
years with
helping out um but so we have this book
and we go through that they have
assignments that they have to take home
with them
which can be things mostly like things
like lifestyle change
so yeah and reading yeah so drinking
more water
um taking contrast showers which opens
the blood vessels and pumps blood to the
frontal lobe
in your brain which is what you need to
function well and overcome your
depression
um and it's things like uh sleeping well
you know and eating a plant-based diet
it's very simple things that people do
and most people are just not used to
that they like i've never heard what is
a contrast shower why would i do that
i have to need an apple right what are
you talking about i just had an app on
their way here
i was like yum healthy calories
so there was something else you said too
and i want to back up just for our
audience sake
you had mentioned from the get-go that
you were seeing a lot of depression
now in in in younger people and i can i
can just hear some people out there
you know like well that's kind of normal
you go through your teen years you get
depressed
so what's different you've been a
physician now for probably 20 plus years
30 years so there's probably always been
some depression
during those younger years what's
different
now or as things have progressed versus
then like
have you are you seen like i just
noticed like it was double or
or what are we getting at because we're
not i don't think we're here today
because
depression is just like baseline i think
we're here today because depression is
on the rise so can you speak to that a
little bit right yes
i mean when you look at uh puberty
and all the hormonal changes that takes
place in young people yes it's it is a
turmoil
time of a young person's life and
there's an adjustment from being a child
to being an adult
and so there are some challenges
emotionally that these kids face
and those things do happen and that has
always been there you're right
but the numbers are definitely on the
rise i could
i would probably say easily that of all
the young people under 18 that i see on
a regular basis at least
50 of them are on some kind of mood
altering medication
now to me that's staggering that's okay
that's a lot
you know a year and there some you know
i could still say fine you know there's
some kids that struggle
with that transition but the majority
you know when it's
50 you know i then my little red flags
go up
and i'm asking questions like what's
going on here why is this happening
would you know
just by having a casual conversation
with them
um it depends on the questions you ask
them you see most people just ask you
know
you know how do you get along with your
parents or what's happening or
you know i'm stressed out over my school
and all those kind of things but
very few physicians actually go into you
know
lifestyle stuff looking for those causes
and certainly when it comes to you know
what are you putting in your mind you
know we're beginning to catch on that
the stuff we put on our body affects our
health
and most people are kind of aware of
that whether they practice or not
that's another story but when it comes
to what am i putting in my mind what
music am i listening to what am i
watching what am i spending my time on
people just don't seem to be thinking
that that might have an effect
so you're asking the leading questions
as a physician but what about the
average person like do their parents
know they're depressed
do do their friends know they're
depressed or is it something that's like
we're missing
many times the family doesn't know i've
had okay
you know phone calls from a friend
saying
my friend is in her room her mother
doesn't know she is extremely depressed
and suicidal
please can you help us but she cannot
tell her parents
so that's really scary to think about to
have you know you meet a teenager
13 to 19 any given teenager and one in
two that you come across
are depressed that's the scary thing and
to think that you wouldn't
know well if you look at if you're sorry
if you look at
you know the research that james dobson
and focus on the family
has done over communication between
parents and their their young people
uh the average number of seconds
per day that those people have in
meaningful communication i mean we're
talking less than a minute
you know and so how in the world are you
going to find out what's really going on
in the heart of your child
your teenager you don't spend any time
or with them you know
they watch tv together they're on the
internet together but they don't speak
and communicate with one another
family dinners having fun yeah
you know i think that there's a i have a
theory on this as well
uh i'm a parent right i've never done
this before
like like who's done this before right
you're kind of going through it and
you're like well yeah my kids kind of
like
maybe depressed or whatever but you know
in some situations
maybe because these parents have nothing
to judge that from
they're just like well we've heard that
you know teenagers are rough years and
my kid spends all his time
in the in the room but i think that's
also like you guys brought out a
testament
we need to spend time with those kids be
intentional
my wife and i try to read parenting
books all the time and it's like they
keep hammering this one concept
you come and spend time with your kid in
their world
not like always inviting the kid to go
and do what you want to do you need to
immerse yourself in their world
and build that relationship and then
hopefully you know they'll you'll
recognize or see some of those things
and i think another uh reason why people
don't notice is
is that some function some families are
dysfunctional yeah and so
you know the bible says that um the sins
be
going down from generation to generation
i see it the same way as mental health
you have whole slews of family lines
going down where
nobody breaks that tie and gets help
and so it gets passed on and passed on
and passed on until somebody finally
says you know what
there's an issue here let me get some
help let me get some therapy or
something
um and so if you as a parent are
emotionally dysfunctional which often
you don't even know you have no clue
that you're dysfunctional or emotionally
unhealthy
then you're so absorbed with your own
stuff there's no way you're going to
take care of your child properly and
actually notice what their
issues are or if you notice it you don't
have the capacity to take care of them
so what would you guys say to that if if
if there's a parent out here listening
and they're like you know man i'm
starting to recognize a few of these
little subtle
things about my child what do i do i
have in counseling dealt with
you know parents that sometimes come in
and say i'm here because of my teenager
and i just
i don't know what to do so you know i
tell them the first thing is
be everything you want your teenager to
be
you yourself if you don't want them in
alcohol or drugs or anything you don't
be
taking any substances yourself if you
want them to be
a christian that lives according to the
word of god then you be daily in the
word that's right
um so the first thing that i tell a
parent is you be
everything you want your child to be now
i know we didn't get to your
introduction really but
you are a counselor in fact you're
you're in the
the throes of this right now so i'll be
graduating in two weeks
beautiful beautiful so tell us a little
bit about what got you into that why'd
you choose that
well what got me into it really was dr
nedley and the
nedley program erica nedley and i worked
as a program director
in the three programs also took my
training in weimar california
and you know dr nedley has really this
is a landmark work that he has written
and um it gives us tools
for dealing with loss in our lives it
gives us tools for dealing with
even things that we might be addicted to
and
but natural tools that we can use at
times when you know we come into a
crisis that we have tools how to deal
with that
and we all will at some time in our life
suffer a loss
you know or or be put in an extremely
stressful situation
and to have those tools and also then um
like this little book is one of the
books that we recommend in the program
telling yourself the truth which it's
like christian cognitive behavior
therapy
and then the thing um paul conniff was
our spiritual counselor
in the nearly depression anxiety
recovery program
and coming to the person of jesus christ
and looking at what he went through for
us
and he is my mentor in counseling um
anyway awesome really powerful so so you
as well are seeing this massive
need i mean just just even within our
own
small circle that we have here i mean
who hasn't dealt with depression at some
level right
right my grandfather um his mother
actually ended up committing suicide and
he
married my grandmother whose father
committed suicide
so just in my own family line there's
there's this
depression that trickled down all the
way and you know
it's it's something that i think we can
be proactive about even if you
you don't quite struggle with it
yourself
it would be good to pick up these books
and read them to know what what do i do
in this situation what if my kid has a
has a loss how do i help them through
that right so
awesome very very important yeah we've
even seen people come through a program
who are like well i'm just here to
support my friend
and they go through the program
themselves and they're like i learned so
much
and i grew in my emotional maturity
emotional health and what we call eq
instead of iq eq
where you're able to understand yourself
better your feelings your emotions where
you're coming from
and then also how do you make the right
decisions based on that
instead of just making an emotional
decision you make a more logical
decision that's eq
and yeah like i said i mean for me
personally i think this program is for
everyone not just if you have depression
or anxiety
i think that everybody can grow in their
eq to some extent
which i think even eq helps with um
having healthier families
having healthier marriages because you
understand better yeah i i couldn't
agree more
with danique than that is that this is
really not just a program
for people who have mental or emotional
health challenges
this is really something that should
that should be incorporated in our
school system
it's a human problem it should be part
of of
normal educational curriculums right
yeah because i think everybody can
benefit
we all can improve our emotional
intelligence right and what what
what an an and great space to be in if
you don't struggle with this
and you are perceptive of people around
you i mean even in our work our work
environments people
you can now be a source of help to those
people
rather than maybe dousing them with
gasoline and you know
the product and that's what a high eq is
right yeah right there you've just
described that yeah yeah
awesome but i just want to say that the
program only works when you commit
to working the program you're doing
everything in the program i remember
daddy
when she was in the program she's
something who texts me i'm out running
in the rain it's raining but i'm not
ready
yeah and she just started on her journey
of exercise and now she does half
marathon that's true it's funny because
like
that i was not really that much into
exercise until i went through the
program
and then i got hooked and now i do i
swim three days a week i run three days
a week and i just picked up
strength training six days a week so
exercise is a way that you can
basically start to manage your emotional
you know levels and things like that
right yeah maybe dr derek can explain
that that
um i was on medication at one point what
was the
medication that they described in the
book that if you exercise
it was a dozen ones they compared it
with zoloft
you exercise two hours a day that it's
as powerful or more powerful than that
yeah it's as effective zoloft is
probably the drug that has been most
researched
and studies done so most of the
lifestyle
comparative studies is they compare to
sertraline or zoloft
and so so there's a lot of studies out
on those type of things
and exercise
aerobic as well as weight training and
interval training is as effective
and not if not more than taking zoloft
and and your benefits come earlier
normally most of these antidepressant
medication takes
12 weeks three months to four months
before you get the full efficacy
and before you begin to feel the
difference whereas exercise you can
begin to feel the difference in 10 days
i remember
when i kind of did a little bit of
studying on on depression i remember
kind of coming across these
these studies and these people that had
uh worked with kids and teenagers and
things that were severely depressed
and um this one lady was really
interesting she said that the first
thing
she would try to get these teenagers to
do is
is go out and help somebody just do
something she would take them to soup
kitchen she would take them all over
just to get them outside of their their
own space where they can't see beyond
their own little bubble you know
and and that was one way that she kind
of began to crack
through to them and it was kind of like
as they were helping other people it was
in turn
actually helping them yes right right
and taniki you've
i'm sure you've experienced that because
a year later after you came into our
program that you took your training and
now
yeah and it's so fulfilling you're such
an awesome facilitator
thank you in our small group sessions
and she's such a blessing
and i love that this program actually
swings back around and says now we want
to kind of
t make you a teacher yeah because right
you can't teach somebody something you
don't know
yes so by actually showing somebody
something else
i mean it's like you're soaking it in
and you're digesting it more so
it's even becoming that the helper is
then helping you
yeah and it's really useful especially
because like i've been through it and
and depression
can be caused by so many things but
there's always one person who has gone
through a similar experience and as a
facilitator i try to be open about that
like
and it's and it's a you know a private
space like we don't go out and share
oh this person's in my program and this
person is suicidal or
is depressed or has anxiety or has an
eating disorder or something like that
but we yeah so we it's a closed space
and then we all can share once they're
ready because we never force
anybody to share anything but once
they're ready they want to talk about it
and we once had a women's group like 14
15 women
everybody connected so much
where if people started crying they they
just were
there for each other and it was
incredible to see that and that they
could
actually it's not just us that is like
helping them it's they are helping each
other and it's it's so powerful
okay you bring up a really interesting
point that i want to kind of explore a
little bit here
because we and and correct me if i'm
wrong because i'm not a psychologist or
or anybody that's really studied mental
health in-depth lead like that
um but when we watch other people have
tears and
you know it's like we feel empathy for
them and we kind of feel what they're
feeling right
and so that's why sometimes those groups
it's like you can find somebody that
that really you know identifies with
what you're doing
so i kind of want to swing the
conversation back to media what if
you're watching all this
terrible things depressing things but if
you're listening to depressing music how
does that
impact your mental health well
uh i think again most people don't
realize what it does
and the things we observe
and the things we watch forms
the thought patterns in our minds now
everything that we do originates from a
thought
now we used to think that thoughts are
just electrical activities like
lightning it strikes there and you can
never go back and
trace the path but we now know that
that's not the case
every thought that you ever think is
physically in your brain that you can
feel it you can touch it and you can see
it you can actually take a picture of it
and you can go back with a probe and
stimulate
that area and make the person think the
same thought over and over and over
again
so whatever we put in our minds uh
that stimulates our thinking creates
little neurological pathways in your
brain
like that saying like let's see create
actions go and get actions yeah and so
the more you
exercise that thought the stronger and
stronger it gets until it becomes a
default
thought it's like a big old
interstate you know so and when that
stimulus come
you get on the interstate because it's
there's no traffic lights that you can
go
an 80 mile an hour and it's quick and so
and then you go down that pathway and it
creates
certain actions and actions makes habits
and habits
you know create your character and so we
know and so what you put in your mind
and what you watch and what you listen
to is extremely important
because you're continually creating and
growing your brain
so the way i've always understood this
and you can correct me if i'm wrong is
by building those pathways your brain is
electrochemical
so electricity always follows the path
of least resistance yes
so the bigger the wire the more likely
it's going to go down that
yes absolutely yeah and from what i
understand is that you can recreate
those pathways right basically destroy
the ones that are bad
so in my mind i'm thinking like you guys
say a highway
it's easy and then all of a sudden you
want to change your habit it's like
going down is this dirt road with
potholes and it's hard
but if you keep progressing it will turn
into a highway eventually
and it's a healthy highway yes well and
and that's what we teach in in cognitive
behavior therapy right
which for me as a christian counselor is
christ-centred cbt and
and biblical cbt and that is that those
thought patterns is what we want to we
want to think about what we are thinking
metacognition so when i'm feeling this
distress when i'm feeling this
anger or this strong emotion what am i
thinking what am i actually telling
myself like
and then you know how can i change that
thought
to something that is based on god's
truth
and something that is is based on what
god would have me think
and that's for me as a counselor you
know it's not just about
healthier thinking it's about thinking
god's thoughts
you know and and memorizing some
scriptures
i give my clients um i identity in
christ
scriptures about 30 scriptures on their
identity in jesus christ
because you know when we look at jesus
all
almost all the attacks that he had from
satan
was against his identity if you are the
son of god
then do this so the attack was against
his identity and satan attacks
us on our identity he doesn't want us
to realize the incredible identity we
have in jesus christ
but we adopted into his family we're
made in the image and likeness of god
that we are bored by the blood of jesus
and
um so anyway so i give them the 30
scriptures and just a little summary of
each scripture and when they wake up in
the morning
to first um read through 10 of those
and to realize that in christ i am
seated in heavenly places in christ i've
already received eternal life
in christ there's no condemnation for me
today nobody can take me out of his hand
and then to take one of those each of
those little scriptures put it on
a note card and carry it with them and
memorize that scripture
i had one client who came very depressed
and actually just recently she'd been
suicidal and
was going through a really really rough
time and she started doing that and she
said to me
my thought pattern has changed entirely
instead of focusing on these negative
thoughts
about how terrible my situation is and
she was going through a really hard time
she said i'm thinking about who i am in
jesus christ
and that in christ i can do all things
and he strengthens me
anyway it's just really powerful so if
if you really as a christian understand
the transforming power of god's word
i mean just just think of that thought
right yes god says let there be light
bam it needs those words that went out
of his mouth that
created that action right there's
there's examples of that all throughout
the bible when jesus was in the boat
with the disciples right he stood up and
he said peace be still
the waves and the wind and everything
obeyed him why simply because he
said it right so that's why i believe
what you're doing and encouraging people
to do is
so powerful if you literally did like
you know nothing else and you really
just understood that concept
believe that concept that god has
transforming power in his word
he would do wonders for him wonders and
uh but the thing that we need to realize
with that as well
is is that because
our thoughts are physical
sheer willpower is not enough
to change it doesn't matter how strong
your will is that's right
you have to physically destroy those
neurological pathways in your mind
right and so when so i explain it to my
patients like this that
you know if if you don't feel really
well you go into your room then you put
your headphones on
and you put that rock and roll song in
there that's got that bad lyrics and it
makes you feel
sad your brain goes to work because
somewhere in your mind
that thought that creates those emotions
are there
and so then you it's like your brain
goes in then this
you've got a whole library of all these
dvds there and it goes
and it finds that sad song and now it
puts it in the cd-rom drive
and you play your sad song and now
you're experiencing all those feelings
and stuff
because he wants those old pathways yes
now what you need to do is
if you want to change you need to when
that cd is taken out and put in the you
need to stop it
and scratch it you need to destroy it so
now if you scratch it once
and you put it in the disc player it's
not going to play okay you need to
scratch it again and
you can scratch it twice and you put the
dvd in and it's still going to play yeah
you need to scratch it and scratch it
and scratch it in the same way that it
takes 21 times to create a new habit
you have to destroy that old pathway
21 times or however long it takes until
when one day you take that disc out and
you put it in and it doesn't want to
play
and now you put in its place
the new empowering thoughts that's an
important
concept yes you have to replace it you
have to replace
it any anybody who struggles with any
sort of addiction that's the one thing
they teach you
outside of god you can set god aside you
cannot just
cut this thing out of your life no and
fix it you must
replace it with something positive
because otherwise it's like the high was
here but there's no dirt road to to
drive on right so
it's like where do you go yeah go ahead
no i'm just going to say that
the way i understand is in your brain
that
physical pathway is actually broken yes
when that happens
that's a powerful thought like something
in your brain can
get broken like that actually physically
like that wire is snapped it's snap but
not just not just that
this is what neuroplasticity is about
okay
is that they can actually take pictures
of somebody's brain and show certain
pathways in certain and
anatomical way the brain in that
particular area is high-powered
photography
they put this person through cognitive
behavioral therapy where they
put new thoughts destroy old ones and
when they go back
and they take a picture of the same
place it looks different
stuff goes over stuff goes over pathways
change things happen
it's amazing it's very powerful
empowering thought i remember neil
nedley giving an example and he said
it's like walking through a wheat field
and the first time that you walk through
that wheat field in a new direction so
you so it's off the pathway that you
normally are walking
it's difficult i mean you're having to
push you know plants and weeds aside and
you know trudge this new path
it's gonna be hard but the more that you
actually travel that path
the more that ground will be trodden
down and easier and easier to get so
i'm sure that first time you pull that
cd out and you scratch it the first time
i mean lots of things are going through
your head right i paid for this i'll
never be able to listen to this again i
mean this is a lot of
oops it takes a lot of of will you know
to
actually make that first scratch but the
more scratches that you make
the more times you do that yes yeah i'm
just thinking of um
because we're talking about media i'm
thinking of social media how
um so we're trying to create these new
pathways and i do think there's certain
things we can do in our life
to hinder that and i think social media
is one of those places
um you know i i recently uh was an
instagram and i
um saw this this one girl
and i was kind of shocked because i was
like how is this allowed to be
on instagram she was an influencer
apparently but she was
one she was literally you could see her
ribs that's
i think she was had anorexia or
something um but two then she posted
pictures of herself
that were so almost nude
like i was shocked because i thought if
she didn't have the clothes on it was
literally pouring without she was
posing and i the thought went through
her mind of this girl must have had been
through some kind of a sexual assault or
something
because that's very often the reason why
they show themselves like this
and then she had a post on there where
she said that and um
you know there's other people that i see
that
constantly almost every single post on
instagram
is selfies of themselves over and over
and over and over again
and some people might think they're
arrogant but that's not the case
they're extremely insecure to the point
where they need to get attention from
other people yeah
and so thinking of that with social
media it's like social media is
can be interesting it can be fun i use
it for our young adult group to post
stuff about
you know bible studies or hikes or
something it's useful
it can be used as a ministry tool it can
also be an obstacle block especially for
women
that go on there that see these perfect
people
and compare themselves with them but you
don't realize the 500 pictures they took
the filters the the angles the light i
mean they
they got it right and photoshop
photoshopping yeah
yeah yeah yeah face tuning and
everything else
to the point where where you think those
people are happy like you see these
influencers
with the really handsome guy who is
completely chiseled and has a tan and
has the blonde
ken hair from like barbie and ken you
know and like the girl who's
perfect and the baby who's perfect but
you don't know are they actually perfect
you don't know these people they portray
to me perfect
but they might be struggling with stuff
and they'll be hiding that
right exactly yeah so i just want to
highlight two things about
this since you mentioned selfie we did a
whole documentary on selfie keith tell
us a little bit about that
what that's all about so yeah i mean
several years ago when we started to see
all this on their eyes
we did a documentary called selfie and
we'd really talk about the scientific
the medical
i had one of the doctors in my church
feeding me medical journals so i could
do research and pour through articles
and stuff
and just the social phenomenon there's
even a video i included in here
and i like to show when i speak to
people of
it's a social experiment nice and i show
a child
how easy it is to abduct a child and
then i say now could you do that with
social media
and then i show them teenage girls much
older than the little kids
falling for basically the same principle
using social media so it's a powerful
tool
and i remember there was this one time i
was i was giving this presentation i was
in chicago
and i had been talking about
social media and what goes on and just
how easy it is to
influence people with technology and get
into their computer and you know all the
different ways you could do that
i sat down after it was done and the guy
that invited me
he leaned over and he's like hey the guy
that
um is sitting next to me he works for
the fbi
and i was like oh no i'm in so much
trouble
but the next thing he said was really
encouraging he said everything you just
said was exactly right and apparently he
worked in cyber crimes
division and he you know validated his
like yeah i see this kind of stuff
happen all the time and another friend
of mine
who works for a sheriff's department or
did he told me the first place he goes
to look for a criminal
social media he's like you would be
surprised what people post
on the internet yeah so yeah you're
right it is very powerful and so we
cover a lot of those concepts
in that documentary the other one i want
to highlight is the social dilemma you
guys brought this up
because i remember when i watched that
um i was just like
oh oh my goodness like my child is never
gonna play with this thing you know it
was just
literally like wow this is a thing
that can easily get out of hand and um
so
definitely we'll put a link to to that
and to where to get this but
uh also the other thing that was brought
out of that was just the increase like
you guys mentioned earlier
about depression and suicide and these
things i mean you can see the direct
graph
yes it's it's kind of on an incline but
then all of a sudden you see where
social media hit the scene and it's just
exponentially it goes up like
this eating disorders we're seeing more
bulimia
why why why are we seeing that what's
the psychology behind that or what's the
what's the reason we're looking at this
and all of a sudden now it's impacting
us in this way
well everybody posts their best moment
right photoshop say pictures and
you know these people have lost their
lives trying to take selfies
you know so it's almost like it's an
obsession that i have to have the selfie
at the edge of this cliff at the edge of
the grand canyon
you know um with the shark right there
then you know it's the best moment it's
almost like a competition to see who can
have this absolute best moment
to portray as if i am living this
unbelievable
great life that is better than
whoever else is out there is life um and
so people that are
maybe going through a hard time or maybe
suffering through
you know a depressive situat a very
difficult situation
suffering a loss or you know suffering
some kind of loss of relationship or
something in their life and now they're
scrolling through social media
and they just get the impression
everyone else is having this
unbelievable life
and you know it causes more depression
and i'm sad to see the the rise in in
eating disorders and
it's it's really about the the uh
title of your other video which is
called the psychology of
lying it's all lies we are we are being
sold
lies we live in a world of lies you know
people don't realize that
you go to the gas station and how much
is the gas
259 and nine tenths of a cent
there's no nine tenths of a cent okay
you know but it just looks
but it's a lie it's a subtle lie that
they give you because it draws you
and so wherever we look there's lies i
mean every magazine cover is a lie
every uh advertisement is a lie you know
the movies are lies
i have a bible verse for you to read
james 3 16 we brought this up for where
you have envy and selfish ambition
there you will find every evil practice
i mean think about that the devil's not
dumb he knows
hey if i create selfishness in this in
this group of people then that will open
the floodgates to any manner of evil
evil so you know you sit here and think
about this
from a logical perspective it's like
okay i'm using social media
and uh you know i'm trying to fill a
void in my life and
and i'm depressed and it's really
reinforcing that depression
so why am i doing it right it's not
really fulfilling that need so
can you speak to why
people do it i mean there's an addiction
there that is happening
what's going on with that addiction what
what are the you know what's going on in
the brain what's what's going on with
the body that's that's causing them to
keep doing it
well i think that one needs to realize
that uh
with all these things there's a certain
amount of initial pleasure
that people experience i mean if
if i were just to give you arsenic there
on the table but i don't coat it in
in a chocolate and you know that make it
look like an m
m nobody's going to eat it but when it
looks like an m m
then we'll take it and so initially i
don't die immediately i first get some
enjoyment and so
the devil is not stupid like you said
you know there's some enjoyment in
most of these things the reason is
because
god has created us that way there are
receptors in our brain that releases
dopamine
all these feel good hormones and
chemicals
that gives us pleasure but when we have
a super stimulus
you see that's where the problem comes
is that we're exploiting the system
and now we have a super stimulus and
that's where the the problem comes sorry
you wanted to say something
sorry i'm going to be interrupting you
but um
in the social dilemma it shows how they
have used psychology
to build addiction into social media
that was an alarming fact right that was
a very alarming to me when i watched
that but it was premeditated they
thought about it
they executed with precision and and
like literally now they're coming out on
the other side going hey we knew we were
doing this
and we feel terrible i mean we've
literally ruined society
yeah it's a bigger monster than we ever
you know it's a much bigger thing than
we ever thought it would be but they
forget it they forget about it very
quickly
but but all those little every time
every time you get that little buzz
that little beep that little like that
you know
that stimulates you oh let me go and see
oh here's a message here
you know how many people like my picture
those are all
it's like a little mouse that you know
gets a reward
every time it's yeah it's the psychology
of addiction like i'm thinking of these
people that i see on my social media
that constantly upload selfies like if
you go to their page on instagram
they're great it's just
90 pictures of themselves and they're
all the same you know it's like
my face this day my face that day but
you know like this is what i had for
lunch right right yeah
but it's but it's you know people like
that they struggle with
like i said insecurity and emptiness but
it's those likes
that gives them that attention and it's
the dopamine
but it's not going to get you to where
you need to be you're going to be stuck
in a cycle for the rest of your life
and what you really need at that point
is help and therapy
so that you don't have to be a prisoner
to
those likes anymore because no one wants
to live like that it's not
fulfilling you yeah that then becomes
your validation or your worth
your self-worth rather than jesus came
down and died the very king of the
universe
i mean he left every comfort that he has
up there because he would have done that
just simply for you
i mean outside of everyone else it would
have just happened just for you so
and i should add to that that very often
i believe
when people struggle with those kind of
things you know um
using somebody else to fill their void
whether it's through likes whether it's
watching other people on instagram live
a good life or facebook or whatever
youtube i i believe that very often
there is something else going on there
are some kind of roots
maybe it's some kind of an issue in
their upbringing maybe they grew up in a
dysfunctional family that already
imprinted
into them as a child you are not worthy
you are not valuable and uh you cannot
find
worth and so there then they go into
into
instagram and it's just the result of it
but it's not the root of the problem
it is a god-shaped hole in everybody's
heart
that is so big only god can feel it
and if we are filling that hole
ourselves we're going to fill it with
addictive substances you know
yeah i'm just thinking of how amazing
that thought really is because
you think about what you're trading for
like this small
little affirmation from from other
people
compared to what god is offering yes
like if you think about it it's like
well what would you want
more like what is god offering you yeah
it's so much more than what other people
are offering you
and forever versus the the temporary
moment in time that we
exchange for you know to get that
validation it's incredible
if we think about it just sit there and
meditate on that it's like well
why would i want that versus this well
and that that's what i
would like to bring us to here right now
in isaiah 53
it says that jesus was despised
and rejected by people he was a man of
sorrows familiar with suffering
he was despised like one from whom
people turn their faces
and we didn't consider him to be worth
anything
he certainly has taken upon himself our
suffering
and carried our sorrows but we thought
that god had wounded him beat him and
punished him
he was wounded for our rebellious acts
he was crushed for our sins he was
punished so that we could have peace
and we received healing from these
wounds so we know that jesus died for
our sins but
why did he suffer so much
and if we um turn to hebrews um the book
of hebrews chapter 2
it says that
christ was tempted on all points like as
we are
yet without sin and so if we look at the
life of jesus we see that he was born
from an unmarried mother
he had a stepfather his family were
refugees
they had to escape to egypt
shortly when he was just very small
he was tempted to be deceived by satan
in the wilderness
to put his trust in his own power for
himself to prove who he
was and to prove his identity he was
tempted without sin
he was tempted with lust
you know we know the situation where
mary continued kissing his feet while
she was
washing them with her hair jesus was
tempted on all points like as we are yet
without sin
he was rejected by love by his loved
ones he was abandoned
pretty much by everyone who knew him and
finally you know he was physically
emotionally
mentally abused stripped naked hung on
the cross
and while he was on the cross he asked
the question my god my god
why have you forsaken me so it's okay to
ask god
why right um and he was tempted to use a
substance when he was on the cross to
numb
his pain by using a substance and um
just in the last couple of weeks here i
met a lady who you know was
just sharing her tragedy of her story
and she said at one point i was homeless
and i was like
jesus was homeless he had no place to
lay his head
but he came to identify with us in our
suffering
so that our story can identify with his
story
and that through his suffering we
receive healing is what the bible says
it's almost like when you're depressed
you want to watch depressing movies or
listen to depressing music right
because there's something about needing
to identify with that right
but here we have an individual that has
gone through anything that you could
possibly go through on this planet and
probably even more severe
in every way yes and and so if you're
struggling and you you you know you're
looking for
someone to connect with and identify man
jesus is your man
he's your god he's the king you see
where he came from right and it makes it
even more powerful
yeah that's right thank you for sharing
that that's beautiful he came as a baby
you know what god would become so
fragile
that we could touch him we could hold
him and we could hurt him
you know then he would allow that to
happen you know what i mean it's just
like amazing yeah
this book the the hidden half of the
gospel i somebody mentioned this to me
when i was in the worst of my depression
and i remember reading this and i was
struggling
with my relationship with god because i
was like why why did you allow these and
these things to happen
like how are you supposed to be my
father when all these things happen how
can i trust you and i
completely at one point rejected god and
i said i've had enough of it
um but this book was such an eye-opener
and it rocked my world to understand
he has been through the same things i've
gone through he has had similar
experiences he understands me
because that's what the book talks about
is that he's been through
every every possible uh situation you've
been through
that jesus has been through as well and
and i would really encourage people who
are struggling because
i i believe that a lot of your people's
anxiety when i struggle with things
um i think a part of that might be
that if you don't have a full trust in
god
it's gonna be so much harder to overcome
but if you have that trust and sometimes
it's like okay
um this chunk of my trust in god's been
healed but it might be this part
and you're like oh look i'm still
struggling with this because not because
only because
of the relationship with god there's
other issues as well but there's like if
you heal that you're going to be so far
their head
so i encourage people one be honest with
god like he is
it's okay to come to god and tell him
what you're thinking and that's what i
did
i said lord i don't trust you i don't
know
i believe that you're real but i don't
understand you how are you supposed to
be my father when this and this and this
happened to me
this doesn't make sense but i said at
one point a friend invited me
said she said you always say that you
want to invite god into your heart again
why don't you do it and i remember we
had this beautiful moment when we cried
and we prayed together
and i got i invited god in my heart
again and it still took me months
months of getting to the point where i
was truly
trusting god i could say okay i believe
that you have the best intentions for me
um but it's just being honest with god
and wrong with god and
i would also say find books that will
answer your questions
because if i have a friend
and that friend has done something that
i don't understand it hurts me
do i just come to conclusions and walk
away from the years and years of
friendship
or do i give the person the benefit of
the doubt and actually talk to that
person and ask questions
and then the person's like no i never
meant to do that right i didn't do that
actually
at all you know like god is like i
didn't do that i actually did what's
best for you
so talk to god about it and find out
why why you believe these things and
read books read the bible what i
appreciate about
the stories of the bible is you can find
characters in the bible as well that you
can simply identify with i love the
story of elijah you know i mean what a
what a cool thing to be on the mount
carmel and you see fire coming down from
heaven and you're like
like my god's stronger than you're going
right literally a few
days later he's running for his life
hundreds of miles and he's just like god
take my life
like i'm done you where were you where
were you protecting me i love how god
answers that
you know he's just like he's not in the
wind he's not in the you know the the
storm he's not in everything he's just
like hey elijah what are you doing
you know god is patient with us and he
can handle that
he's been through it he knows what we
have experienced as
human beings we are caught in this thing
i mean satan's doing this to us
i think it's interesting to me that
everybody pins this on god god what's
wrong with you right why doesn't anyone
turn around and be like devil why are
you doing this
you know what with a satanist i remember
you guys did a show
and there was a satanist that brought up
something and he's like oh what god gave
up a weekend
and it's like wait wait wait what did
satan do he hadn't given up
anything for you in fact he's taken
things from you constantly
god the creator of the universe who has
always been there
gave up his life so that you could have
an opportunity that's beautiful
right well that brings me just the whole
thing brings back to the the very first
question that you asked is what
drew us to this particular
program you know and when you and this
is
one of the things uh that that comes out
is the fact that
when somebody is depressed most people
feel hopeless
because they feel they've tried so many
things
and nothing works you know and they just
say they feel like there's not anything
that i can do
and so that is a probably the worst
position to be in when you have a
feeling of hopelessness
and so what you want to do is you want
to create in somebody hope that
there is light at the end of the tunnel
and when
you look at health in general everything
is about circulation
you know if you're not if you don't have
enough circuit you don't have enough
blood clean to your heart
you have a heart attack and you croak
and you die if you're not in enough
blood going to your brain
you get a stroke if you don't get enough
blood going to the eye
your retina you get macular degeneration
and you go blind
you know and you can go through your
whole body if you don't get enough blood
going to your big toe
if you've got because of your diabetes
it goes gangrenous and you've got to cut
it off
so circulation is important but we also
now know
that if you don't have enough blood
going to your frontal lobe
yet you suffer from mental illness you
suffer from depression and you suffer
from anxiety
and there's something you can do about
it okay
if you follow all these lifestyle
principles because this program is
really
a a new start program on steroids right
okay
it's not only dealing with a with the
physical health aspects
but it's also dealing with a
psychological so when you switch
somebody's body on
you make them start exercising their
heart gets healthier their lungs get
healthier their brain gets healthier
there's blood going to their mind now
when you come to them
with the spiritual aspect and with the
neuroplasticity aspects of cbt
now they can understand it now it makes
sense to them
and then they say i get it i can now
actually see the light at the end of the
tunnel
and now they have hope yeah and that's
what you want and that
that's why neil took away the tvs the
absolutely
the phones and everybody when depressed
patients would come to him because
it decreases the blood flow to the
frontal lobe absolutely by 40
i think is what he said there's
something close to that and uh you know
we want the frontal lobe
activated working that's where we have
our reasoning our spirituality all of
that is transpiring in the frontal lobe
it's kind of like the shekinah glory if
you would you know the place that god is
actually resting in our minds
well the bible says that he will write
his name in our foreheads
and it's very interesting that that's
just where the frontal lobe is you know
that
we we want the character of christ we
want christ in us the mind
we want the mind of christ and
that's that's the the spiritual part of
our brain is that frontal lobe
and something else i want to address is
um
this is like depression anxiety comes in
a longer pro
process i guess but the how many
predators are on
social media um i was watching a video
that's about a year ago i came across
this and i can't remember the name of it
but
it was about this this this team of
people they worked for a company and
so i think it was cyber security company
that's why they made the video
and they picked this one woman who was a
mother probably in like
early 30s or so and they made an account
with her they photoshopped her face to
make her look
really young like an underage girl threw
it on instagram and within minutes
got messages from men and even when they
picked up their voice calls
that they were showing their genitalia
to what they thought
was an innocent girl and then one of
them even
wanted to meet up with her and she then
dressed up like the teenage girl
went to the hotel met up with the man
and he was trying to convince her to
come up to
the room with her so in that sense um
that's a longer pros the process but
there's still
depression and anxiety involved with
that if you are an innocent child and
you get exposed to these things
um one um sexual assault can be hugely
real yeah sexual assault is it can
hugely
um you know affect a
woman's body image later on and their
self-worth and even for boys too
obviously because also boys are also
being lured into it at some point
though mostly it's women and two it
causes depression and anxiety
so just like what i mentioned earlier
with this girl who was on instagram
who was literally skinned over bones
and was posting pictures of herself that
were very sensual
that you know partly because she wanted
attention
so there you go but then there are men
that were coming after her
probably not because she thought her
body was beautiful but because again
she's vulnerable she's vulnerable and
and because they see the sexual photos
and then it's just a cycle where she now
needs craves this attention from men
because of the thing that probably has
happened because she mentioned that it
had actually happened to her
so there you go it's a whole full cycle
that goes round and round and round
just from based off of social media
the most disturbing thing to me about
this is
and it brings us back to the reason why
we're here
and that is is that so few people
actually see
the danger in this particularly the the
older generation begin to realize
something is wrong something is wrong
with my family something is wrong with
my teenager
with my young person but the young
persons
themselves and the people that are into
this and
as you guys know you know in this
business
in many respects you know if you want to
make your business grow if you want
things to happen you got to
use these tools to get your business out
there so you're kind of
forced to be on facebook to be on
instagram to be on all these
things and most people don't realize
how easily they are influenced by this
and the
impact that it has on them and to me
that's disturbing because how are we
going to make people aware
of the fact that you know this is
dangerous to your mental health
the engineers of facebook have told
the public we don't even use it like we
know what this thing is doing
and i refuse to use it in my household
like like what does that say for the
rest of us you know so
yeah yeah well so that how does this
influence how you actually use media
because i mean were you a big movie
watcher big media person
um give me a little bit of experience on
that and then knowing all this
information going through this program
how has that impacted
your media habits at this point yeah i
was drawn to it i started
watching things where i was like i never
watched this stuff and i
um just didn't care anymore and it was a
coping mechanism for me
and so it took a long time to really get
out of that
and say you know what one this is not
making a situation
better two i'm not bringing it to god
i'm just trying to cope and just
squash it and um and three it's a waste
of my time and it took a long time to
really
um crawl out of that and i think it's
because it's so
in our reach i can literally go home and
sit on my couch and turn it on and watch
something whatever i want
you know and so i think yes it has an
impact and
so now i'm very cautious with that and
i'm like
you know what lord i don't want to do
that i don't want to deal with those
things
let me pick up a book and go read a book
because a book for me
you know i'm a creative person i liked i
like the
imaginary world and so i read a good
non-fiction i'm reading one now it's
called the lost girls about
a christian woman and some um immigrants
or something like that it's really
interesting but anyways
so so i and i still have that
idea of you know the images that go
through your mind as you're reading a
book
i can imagine what these people look
like what's happening
even though it's non-fiction it can
still do that to your brain and it's
it's interesting but but it's it's so
different and i noticed that
um reading a book is so much more
relaxing
than watching anything it's just like i
feel like my whole system is calming
down
and on top of that i also try to
incorporate listening to classical music
a lot
which i did not grow up listening to um
until i had
came across some friends who were um you
know musicians into class of music
and until i came through the program and
it's actually medicine
for your brain and helps you overcome
depression i actually drive slower when
i listen to classical music oh yeah
that's true
when i when i have clients that are into
media you know then they'll say
well like you know how do i replace this
and you know a much easier way to
replace something in your life is to put
something good in its place
instead of leaving a blank that's right
right jesus even warned us about that
that you know when we have had something
bad leave our life to fill it with
something good
so then i'd say to them okay well you
know
firstly if you want to watch something
on youtube
whatever choose like there's the whole
book of matthew
in the visual bible there's the whole
book of john
um it is those are magnificently
beautiful movies that are
word for word the scripture and there's
the whole book of acts
you know to to watch those um and then
of course
you know there are people that are doing
all kinds of amazing lectures
you can even watch dr nedley you can
watch paul conniff looking there's
people doing all kinds of amazing
lectures on on youtube
but also audiobooks audiobooks is a very
very
nice way to replace uh media in our
lives and drive in the car
yeah that's amazing i used to listen to
the bible
when i lived in los angeles and i i
really came back to god
um you can cover chunks of the bible
just
driving around i was like oh i finished
the bible what
a few months in a few months yeah that's
right yeah that's what
it is that's what i do yeah edifying
experience of really just using your
time wisely
and filling it with things that are
profitable instead of i just don't think
you know anybody's going to get to
heaven i
i this is my personal belief i don't
think you're going to be like i'm
so glad i watched every one of those
movies yeah yeah you know what i mean i
mean
there's just i think that there's
there's something interesting about how
much time we
waste i think it's going to be the
biggest struggle for us when we get to
heaven
what did i do with my time you know i'm
really glad that you brought out the
aspect of hope because i was really
wanting to go there
in all of this i can see so many people
out there just
being you know what i'm struggling i'm
depressed i don't know what to do next
is is there help what do i do
and there's light at the end of the
tunnel you know for everybody there is
hope there is help it really speaks to
the mission of jesus when he came to
this earth
that's why i'm glad you brought out all
so much of the bible in this
presentation
it tells us in luke chapter 1 verse 79
just as jesus is you know being born
speaking of his mission it says
to give light to those who sit in
darkness in the shadow of death
to guide our feet in the way of peace
you know all those people that are
out there that lack hope that are
struggling
they want peace they want peace in their
lives you know they want
they don't want to be struggling with
these things they don't want the
darkness in their mind and their minds
and so i like how we can point people to
the bible i
like how we can encourage them to take
simple steps
to make improvements in their lives and
if you don't know how to do that you
know if you're struggling
if you're willing god can do the rest
you know so just come to god and say
lord you know i'm willing but i don't
know what to do can you help me and god
will help you
yeah i just want to say that to
people who are viewing this that the
needly depression anxiety recovery
program there's a residential program in
wemo california
but there's also the small programs are
offered in multiple locations
all over this country the eight-week
program
and it is a powerful program it is
phenomenal
and it's not expensive and so if you go
to the website um
nedleydepressionthewayout.com you'll be
able to see where those locations are
that that program is offered
and once you've gone through the program
you are now an alumni of that program
it's
very inexpensive you're pretty much just
paying for your materials
the people who offer this program like
my husband and myself we volunteer our
time
to do this program and it is really
powerful and then you're an
alumni of the program whenever you go
through a difficult time in your life a
difficult transition
you can go back to the program again and
um be reading your materials and
so speaking to that i'm glad you brought
that up do have you
been expanding to where you do this
online or do you try to not do it online
it is available online okay if you go to
drnadleyhealthsolutions.com you can
purchase the program online
okay however having it in person
with a small group is much more
beneficial and
my husband and i just finished running
one this just a few weeks ago
and um we had 11 people in the program
because now of course we have social
distancing and
and we wear masks and that um but you
know we divided into
two small groups and just made them very
small five or six people each
but the people were so grateful just
thanking us that they could have this in
person
and the connections and the interactions
it was really powerful
and with eight week we should say it's
one evening for two hours a week it's
not
okay yeah not everything yeah yeah yeah
yeah
one evening per week but uh so if people
want to get a hold of you guys you guys
got your own youtube page
no your youtubers yeah
and i don't mind giving my phone number
out if somebody has a question and they
would like to
you know just more information or to
talk about it my number is 423
beautiful okay i just wanted to say
something because i i loved you bringing
in the
the hope at the end you know as a as a
physician sometimes
i'm also i'm also board certified with
the american college of lifestyle
medicine
which kind of specializes in the
evidence-based practice of lifestyle
medicine which has
come to fruition in the last 10 years or
so you know we've we've known
as christians we've known some of these
principles from the bible uh
but there was not the science behind it
to
show people that you know this is not
just uh hocus pocus
this is this is real and this works
and so when many times i go get people
and i've been to several doctors
and they dare you know this nobody can
do anything for me i'm not even sure if
you can do something
okay but i've heard something and so i'm
coming to you to see
to be able to give people hope that
listen
you haven't tried everything there's
still some other stuff that you haven't
done
and if they're willing to to commit to
that
and it happens and they begin to
experience the change
to see the joy in their faces it's like
it's like bringing somebody to jesus
and they and they meet him and they find
salvation
okay they've been hopeless i've been
this terrible sinner i've you know i've
done the worst stuff in life
there's no hope for me nobody can
forgive me and then they realize that
that's what life's about and that gives
you joy
you know when you when you bring
somebody to the place where they say you
know
life's worth living yeah and it's not
just for this life
you know helping somebody with a
depression helping somebody with their
health
yeah it's just for this life but then
you bring them to christ that's right
and that's not for the life to come as
well that's right you know it's the
whole bible in a dark tunnel yeah
we want to give you the light absolutely
and that that's what
is joyful and what i enjoy i've seen
people going coming in
where they shook my hand and their hand
was as dead as a fish
they wouldn't look me in the eye and i
instantly knew this person is probably
very close to committing suicide come
out of the program
in eight weeks they smile and they're
happy
and they're depression free that is
insane yeah it's
so fulfilling to help people with that
i'm glad you brought that up
oh yeah that's great well thank you for
sharing uh your experience and your
expertise
and and showing us the way of hope and
that there is light up
the end of the tunnel so i just want to
address our audience as we close
you know there may be some of you you
are out there and you are struggling
there are answers and there is hope
there's not just hope
uh in medical advice and medical
literature and in lifestyle medicine
there is hope and healing in the word of
god too as we discussed
that word can change your life
and so we just want to encourage you if
you need help
there's help there for you and we're
thankful
for everybody who's joined us today and
we will see you guys on another episode
thank you for watching led live take
care
i am
[Music]
i love it i mean i can't watch enough of
this the dualist who they say can speak
with the spirits
the sins will destroy the commandments
forever a suspicious list of names
prompts an investigation
at a local school and concern for
parents the death note is derived from a
japanese animated show
the girl told authorities she got the
idea from a cartoon network show
mom it's mr satan i recognize that voice
[Music]
anywhere
visit our brothers at school for profits
dot tv and watch from babylon to america
which has over
5 million views on youtube alone and
follow it up with america
2 babylon check the description below
for links to this and more
[Music]
you